haig ich bin max und herzlich willkommen
zu einer runde dapd
ich verspreche euch das wird das letzte
mal sein für heute das geld dann kommt
kein spaß
ich werde auch immer wieder andere dinge
aufnehmen aber ich habe euch hier habe
was zu erzählen
gestern vorgestern kann mir keine videos
ich habe mal davon abgesehen
informations videos zu machen weil wir
von verschiedenen bösartigen limited
unter anderem vorgeworfen wird das kann
nur aus info videos besteht ist jetzt
nicht so ganz falsch aber dann dachte
ich mir einfach
falls falls ihr bei sowas infos haben
wollt einfach auf twitter schauen
irgendwie ist es auch nicht sinn der
sache dass das man jede woche circa 1
info video auf youtube hochlädt
ja was gerade los war ich wollte
eigentlich einen blog aufnehmen ich hab
ich was richtig richtig cooles ich freue
mich wirklich richtig darauf zugeschickt
bekommen ihr werdet dann sehen was das
ist im morgigen video denke ich mal und
ruhig fördern
das ist ungünstig wäre dir dann sehen
auf jeden fall und ich habe mir extra
was heißt extra dachte nein ich hab mir
weil er meine kamera ich hätte ein
anleger vor einer ganzen weile kaputt
gegangen ist habe ich mir eine neue
kamera zugelegt und habe da was ganz
cooles empfohlen bekommen von dem
verkäufer in elektronik handelt mein
gott ich habe schon wieder so scheiße
das ist einfach es einfach götter und
verdammt was gutes empfohlen bekommen
und
das haben nicht allzu viele ich werde
schauen dass ich das für die kamera das
system kann man noch ein cooles objektiv
kriege und dann habe ich vielleicht
sondern kleine eigene optik die ein
bisschen nicht in jedem block sieht und
so ich hoffe mal dass das alles so
funktioniert wie es mir vorstelle
auf jeden fall gibt es morgen ein cooles
video von der sache die ich zu geschäfte
kanal wirklich ist richtig lustig glaube
ich also soviel dazu ja auf jeden fall
habe ich mir das gibt kauft weshalb ist
das eigentlich erzählt und ihr erinnert
euch ihr okay es war keine gute ohne ihr
erinnert euch vielleicht irgendwie lag
total er in euch vielleicht auch in die
geschichte wo ich mit meinem auto liegen
geblieben bin ist mir wieder passiert
weil dieses auto dumm ist einfach ich
schaue auf dem parkplatz das alter zu
schreiben aber man ist cool
ich stand auf dem parkplatz und dann
wollte ich wollt ich los fahren darf ist
in arbeit gebunden
ich schon erzählt ich bin durch meine
arbeit habe ich auch fertig falls ich
das nicht erzählt habe seht ihr endlich
kann man sich mit schampus freuen
seine arbeit habe ich fertig und jetzt
habe ich theoretisch mal wieder ein
bisschen mehr zeit für videos aber ich
verspreche lieber nichts ich bin ja
schon so ein kleiner rabauke der gern
mal vergisst videos zu machen und umgang
mit zu mir leid aber ich freue mich auch
schon auf die zeit nach meinem abitur
weil dann habe ich mir vorgenommen
möchte ich erstmal mich definitiv weiter
entwickeln
das qualitativ hochwertige videos machen
und da ein bisschen rein investieren
damit ich mich ein bisschen entwickelt
was machen wir schon spaß muss ich sagen
wenn ich auch immer unregelmäßig bin und
sonst was ich mir macht es immer spaß
vor allen dingen wenn ich irgendwas
gutes mir überlege und ein gutes
feedback bekommen hier zum beispiel der
snapshot video kam mega gut an ich mir
das nicht selbst überlegt habe
diana war und ja es war einfach eine
coole sache so und ich finde es mal cool
haben auch als ihr geschrieben richtig
cooles video habe ich so noch nirgendwo
gesehen und öfters mal sowas und das
freut mich dort wisst ihr und wollte
dass ich mich freue ja dann schreibt mir
liebe kommentare sagen vielleicht sagen
okay ich habe mich hat gewundert dass
sich benutzer recht aber das platz 167
warum
der ist geliebt schreiben bedeutet aber
632 schon wieder wir sind schon wieder
auf platz eins vom von der keulen liste
irgendwie war getan geht einfach immer
also wirklich ich weiß nie es ist immer
gut irgendwie kann ich das
wahrscheinlich hängt es damit zusammen
dass ich dieses spiel wie behindert
gesucht habe aber das ist nur eine
vermutung
ich bin gerade tue nicht pitch ja das
könnte auf jeden fall schluss anfangs
seien aber das allerschlimmste ist
ich sage es nicht wo sonst achtet ihr
erst recht darauf und dann wird euch das
schauens videos keinen spaß mehr machen
ja ich rede schon wieder in rätseln aber
es kommt ein video ist wahr ich hatte
echt eine gute phase
also ich hatte ja in den sommerferien
besonders war ich echt lange sehr
unregelmäßig sowas uploads anging
ich finde jetzt hatte ich eigentlich
ganz gute phase aber die wurde irgendwie
durch die endphase der seminararbeit
bisschen unterbrochen weil ich natürlich
nicht irgendwie mit einem richtigen plan
gearbeitet habe und irgendwie die ferien
oder so frei gehalten absolut natürlich
auf den letzten drücker was hätte die
sonst erwartet angefangen ja mein thema
war übrigens glaube das habe ich auch
schon mal wie gesagt grenzübergängen
zwischen mensch und maschine und
beispiel
also als werk was ich dafür betrachtet
habe habe ich ihn gewählt und es war
echt cool also ich liebe all wenn sie
haben mein lieblings superheld da war es
ein relativ interessant das mal so zu
bitten
aus wissenschaftlicher sicht zu
betrachten aber letztendlich klingt es
auch noch cool und macht nicht wirklich
mehr spaß
also es war aber schon sehr cooles thema
ich habe auch glück mit der lehrerin die
in dem fach haben weil die einfach mega
entspannt ist ich würde ich kann euch
nur wirklich empfehlen habt ihr
irgendwelche fächer bewusst euch drauf
ankommt dann wählt vielleicht auch wenn
euer bestes fach was weiß ich englisch
ist aber ist eine richtige mix gestellt
habt in englisch dann wählt nicht
englisch sondern wählt einfach was wo
ihr denkt der lehrer ist gut und das
thema liegt mir einigermaßen also das
ist so mein tipp an alle schüler lehrer
sympathie ist so wichtig jetzt auch
einkaufen hätte das gedacht folgen
vertieft werde ich jetzt werden hier
schon schul tipps gegeben alter das spaß
ist das denn schon wieder führen schwert
ich feiere das immer so ab wenn ich
irgend ein gutes entscheidenden kriege
ich weiß gar nicht was der hase soll
freunde wir werden mit as rom sind in
diesem winter so nicht genug und münzen
das ist das sei irgendwie günstiger aber
ich gehe trotzdem war auf volles
entscheidungen zumindest für die brust
noch mal 53 ist anständig aber
wahrscheinlich werden wir auf einer
karte weil ich am 06
breaking meister habe meine sachen okay
wir sind auf dieser karte ja immer eine
karte mit wasser aber auch kein weiter
größeres problem ich werde jetzt so
abrasieren gehen mit meinem schwert
freunde irgendwie ich habe aber auch
glück mit den entscheiden des zumindest
den videos ich spiele das ja relativ
häufig so und ich habe mich immer so
glück aber in den videos irgendwie schon
aber umso besser
dann könnt ihr euch freuen sagen
da es wert sind muss man ich bin echt
fertig mit meinem schädel
vielleicht schaffen wir die runde unter
zehn minuten ist für gestern relativ
schnell ab so meine freunde wenn wir
nicht ein hit geben können müssen noch
zwei spieler übrig aber nicht erkämpfen
sich nicht und morgen ist die abgabe von
einer seminararbeit das ist immer mit
einer party verbunden das ist das
einzige was vielleicht eine morgigen
video im weg stehen könnte es gibt aber
immer irgendwas im weg stehen könnte ich
muss irgendwie schauen dass ich mich
nicht zu sehr weghauen mit mich und dann
trotzdem noch ein video aufnehmen kann
keine ahnung wird also auf jeden fall
doppelt lustig weil das was ich mache
sollte man nein ich werde
schwachsinn wenn ich das video morgen
mache dann mache ich es auch nicht so
okay das war's dann von heute bis zum
nächsten mal macht's gut und dann sehen
wir uns